but fans are quickly forming a consensus
opinion about who they would like to see
playing the next Clown Prince of Crime
the roster of villains for the upcoming
the Batman may already be set but it
seems only a matter of time before the
next cinematic incarnation of the Joker
arrives to vex Robert Pattinson Dark
Knight the fan favorite choice for the
role Willem Dafoe who co-starred with
Pattinson and last year's Robert Eggers
directed psychological horror flick the
lighthouse his choral time Trident
preachers Banshee like in the tempest
and plunges right through your college
now it's obvious of fans of no saying
casting Hollywood productions and you
never know the Batman just might flop
spectacularly thereby failing to even
earn a sequel nothing said that we're
going to go ahead and file this fan
casting under w-4 why the hell didn't we
think of that because yeah now that the
notion of Dafoe as the Joker is out
there it certainly seems like the
definition of a no brainer the veteran
actor is possessed of a wiry physicality
which is perfect for the role his facial
structure and toothy grin are also
custom made for Joe Kadam as evidenced
by some twisted fan art courtesy of
Instagram user the Sith Lord Joker his
role in the lights house demonstrated in
one fell swoop that he has incredible
chemistry with Pattinson and also that
his skill at portraying wild-eyed
craziness as an actor has a no way
diminished over the years to top it all
off he already has experience filling
the shoes of an iconic super villain
we'll get into that in a bit
fans on Twitter have been psyching
themselves up to see Willam play Dafoe
of patent sans Batman see what we did
there ever since the lighthouse dropped
last October the flick is essentially a
two-man stage production with Dafoe and
Pattinson continually one-upping each
other and the crazy Department and the
two actors intense chemistry have
lightbulbs popping up over the heads of
Bad fans far and wide twitter user C or
Craven set the scene for the idea right
saying Willem Dafoe was joka in a
post-credits scene of the Batman just
imagine other users asserted that the
Joker was nothing less than the role
that Dafoe was born to play and some
expressed their shock does such a
spot-on casting choice had never come to
fruition before I'll be enough it turns
out that the idea of cussing the foes
the Clown Prince of Crime has been had
before by the guy who wrote the
screenplay that would evolve into Tim
Burton's Batman in an interview at The
Hollywood Reporter in 2018 the fer
recalled that Sam ham who wrote the
initial drafts of Batman had talked him
up for the role of the Joker wish of
course event
he went to jack nicholson de fire record
ham said something about how physically
i would be perfect for the part but they
never offered it to me perhaps
inevitably though Defoe got his chance
to portray a cackling and him super
villain when he was cast as Norman
Osborn's Green Goblin in Sam Raimi's
spider-man in 2002 making his mark on
one of the films that gave birth to the
modern superhero genre we choose to be
of course he absolutely crushed the role
although Raimi and screenwriter David
Koepp made the same mistake Hammond
script doctor Warren scarran have made
with Batman killing off the iconic
villain in his very first appearance
since then Dafoe is dipped his toes into
the superhero pool so to speak in 2018
soccer man in which he popped up as a
titular characters friend and advisor
volcko this would probably not preclude
him from taking on the role of the Joker
though as many fans of theorized of the
Batman and his potential sequels will be
set in a different universe than the
main DC EU timeline we would sure love
for this bit of fun casting to come to
fruition and we hope the people in
charge consider actually making the man
an offer hey Warner Brothers you have
the power to make about fans the world
over freak out just by giving the guy a
call how about it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and at the pal so
you don't miss a single one
you